clément yao bonjour merci d'être en
direct sur rt français l'heure c'est une
note accablante que vient de publier
l'onu comment expliquer ces exactions
commises contre les civils
le mot il n'est pas assez fort assez
fort mais qui est normal mais malienne
et on doit d'abord relever que c'est
assez content c'est une armée qui n'a
pas reçu la formation adéquate c'est mon
avis parce que une armée qui a reçu une
formation adéquate qui j'ai de quoi et
qu'y d'avoir cette formation morale
éthique à qui signifie que dans pendant
l'instruction de ces militaires doivent
enseigner donc les règles de
comportement tout situation en toute
circonstance et ses 1000 tendance à
couper de ses règles et elles sont
basées sur le respect des droits de
l'homme notamment si la convention de
genève qui date du 12 août 1949 savez de
quoi cela veut dire qu'il faut protéger
les civils est donc l épisode est gay il
ya une façon d'être et et quand une
somme record
ces personnes sont en temps de guerre
alors tous ces règles sont violées alors
je pense que aujourd'hui
loli doit doit monter au créneau est
vrai que les débats liés non parce que
là on voit qu'il ya une chape de plomb
qui existait un silence total
enfin la combi dénoncé ces militaires
les traduits devant les juridictions non
seulement nationale malienne également
été nationale justement en parlant des
deux c'est qu'un sur les 632 qui on
était
voilà nos terres il relevé en tout cas
par l'onu 94 exécutions sommaires sont
imputés aux forces de défense et de
sécurité malienne est ce qu'aujourd'hui
une partie de l'armée est devenue une
milice hors de contrôle
oui oui c'est ce que je disais tantôt
parce que m il teste ses lecteurs c'est
quelqu'un qui a reçu une formation biais
d'une formation à l'éthique morale et
céladon à mes doigts améris invités à
respecter un certain nombre de
comportements
ensuite personne et guay savait de quoi
il faut protéger les civils est donc
traitée de façon décente les prisonniers
de guerre c'est pas l'état au mali parce
que ces prisonniers de guerre mais les
civils sont exécutées de façon sûre mais
alors dans tout cela mais je mets en
cause la formation il s'est laissé
militairement mois ci sont pas des
militaires je vais plutôt les traités
des milices les notes révèlent également
l'implication des armes et burkinabé
nigérienne elles sont mises en cause
justement dans ces exécutions
extrajudiciaires de masse qui est censée
contrôler c'est armée étrangère qui
interviennent sur le territoire malien
je pense que c'était le cas de l'apport
que tous ses amis étaient guéris maliens
notamment dans les centres dans le nord
voilà et tous et la pose encore une
formation et mieux c'est parce que ces
petits zones échappent complètement au
pouvoir de bamako et c'est donc des
zones de non droit où chaque psp mais
c'est ce qu'il veut c'est vrai que on
insiste certainement un certain nombre
de règlements des comptes parce que
quand on voit un peu toutes les forces
en présence notamment et les forces
ottomanes civile à l'appel à balard et
les dozos et les forces que les forces
de gauche et tous ce village là quelles
situations instables une situation
incontrôlable
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir que l'onu
est un régal et moi beaucoup plus
longtemps et beaucoup plus spécifiée sur
la présente semaine il paie pas cette
zone du mali alors faudrait que des
armées qui a beaucoup malienne aux
autres nigérienne on ferait qu' au
niveau des différents états d'âme agents
habilités à avoir ce comportement le
respect dont d'épisodes gay également
des civils et leurs cotations des civils
bamako est actuellement secoué par un
mouvement de contestation puisque
l'opposition réclame le départ du
résident et brahim boubacar keïta est ce
que ce rapport de l'onu risque de
nourrir un peu plus la colère des
manifestants selon vous oui c'est
vraiment un buteur puisque celle colère
s'est nourri de tous qui papa au niveau
de bamako où il voulait pouvoir des
idées kairaba takita tout ce qu'on lui
reproche c'est vrai on appelle ce
pouvoir était capable donc de sécuriser
tout mali là mais malien n'a pas encore
pu donc otc coesys pour les territoires
également sécurisé également la
population civile
c'est tout cela qu'on lui répond
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ces rapports
l'onu sur la place est accablant qu'on
nourrit donc on va dit quoi et c'est
tout c'est même station qui sont donc
eux mais le contre-pouvoir d ib cas
alors je pense que il va falloir que les
airs en dehors donc l'onu noté il
fallait que la cedeao et l'union
africaine répète encore une manip essaie
de calmer le jeu parce que c'est jamais
le pouvoir de bamako tomber à marseille
vers une véritable catastrophe annoncée
le trouve dans un lieu d'un état de non
droit où ça sera carrément l'anarchie
voudra me fallait donc protéger d'abord
ce pouvoir il fait en sorte que ces
différents force et en présence puisse
trouver un accord et que ces forces là
finalement laissé bkt mais son mandat et
certainement aux prochaines élections si
bkc n'est pas dans cette coalition qui
l'a conduit pas à l'imam dicko qui sait
qu il fallait que ça s'est passé de
façon démocrate et et non à la france
qui va puisque des désastres et des
désordres au mali merci beaucoup
clément yao d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur du magazine l'afrique
aujourd'hui